what's up everybody welcome back welcome
video I was listening to some some
material podcast and it came up and how
important it is to have a sense of humor
about yourself about the world around
you to not take things to critically
it's not get offended by little things
I just wanted to riff on that a little
maybe maybe give it a little bit of an
explanation because man so many people
are just so easily offended it's really
important for your career even your
relationships around you and everybody's
a little bit different you know if you
can take it you can give it usually that
makes things around you a little more
lighthearted not so tense and it kind of
kind of shows you that you know you have
some resilience you're not not just
gonna fold it the first sign of a
struggle or difficulty and that's that's
what people need a team people that are
actually devoted then I'm just gonna
give up right away as soon as there's a
sign of difficulty
now that's not saying that it's not
worth reanalyzing sometimes it's like
whoa this was way more difficult than I
thought not giving up
but let's reanalyze the situation maybe
there's a better way of doing this or
maybe it's not even worth doing this
because the you know the ultimate payoff
is so mind you compared to the amount of
work it requires so let's just abandon
this do it a different way you know this
it's important to have that critical
sense and that all comes with a sense of
humor because you've got to be honest
with yourself you got it you got to be
able to say all right look
that didn't work was a little silly but
at least I gave a shot and I know better
now and not now I think I need to go ask
somebody that knows more about this what
what a better way might be and see what
you can do from there you know you got
to got to have that sense
when you do things and you don't correct
it you're training yourself to keep
doing it the wrong way
so it's really important to recognize
and not just recognize but also correct
and sometimes you have to force yourself
to correct it at first it's like alright
I got a lot of pride I don't want to go
get help
I feel like everybody's gonna know I'm
not good at this if I go get help it's
like wait a minute
wait
there's a problem with that statement
everybody's going to know that you're
not good at this if you ask for help
well then pretending you are good at it
is essentially living living alone
there's not much good about that either
it's it's better to be honest to be like
look some of this isn't clicking it's I
could use a better explanation on this
why you got to ask yourself why why
don't I understand it and there could be
a lot of different answers that come to
mind like it could be I'm a bit tired
like maybe I'll just get some rest after
I wake up
you go for a walk or something some
things thanks for clicking try that it
doesn't quite work ok still not quite
working I've gave it my honest attempt
of looking at it sleeping on it I'm
trying to see a few different angles
still not quite clicking even though it
feels like a judge you know whatever it
doesn't matter that's when you need to
go ask for help and you could even ask
for help before doing the thinking on a
thing but if you feel like you feel
foggy feel like maybe I could be it a
bit sharper wait and give it another try
and go do that by all means and then go
ask for no and that's way better than
just well and out it then just beat your
head against the wall and be thrown
harsh to yourself as far as your self
esteem just none of that's good you got
to retrain that out
this all goes along with being able to
have a sense of humor trying to take a
way to say it my own way but I'll go
back I'll go back into my personal
history when I was more easily bent out
of shape about things when I was much
younger when I didn't take nicknames
well unless I like the nickname and that
sort of thing
it's way different Karina I see if
someone gives me a nickname
[Music]
I really it doesn't matter how bad the
nickname is my only reaction is to smile
and be happy about it
and it's weird to take even say that
honestly because what if someone
what if someone called me a nutjob for
example that's that's not a very good
name okay listen up a nut job
why don't you know someone says that to
you most people are gonna be offended me
in the past I would have been offended
but I could not a nut job would only be
a nut job but let's be honest they're
calling you a nut job you're probably
doing something that's making you look
like a nut job no it doesn't necessarily
mean you're a nut job but it gives you
they're telling you something that you
wouldn't necessarily know otherwise it's
a case-by-case situation there's a lot
of rules thumbs you can go off of a
general you're gonna have to feel it out
but it never really works to get angry
about it that's not gonna really help
much if you could approach it in a way
where it's like this guy sees something
he's trying to come up with you know a
bit of wit to make a nickname let's find
out what his reason is maybe there's
something behind it and maybe he knows a
way better way of doing what something
you're doing and then if you can like
win this person over with a bit of
weight of your own and humor and bit up
kind-hearted truth this that's not to
not to out there they'll let you they'll
let you in on a secret and it'll save
you a lot of time and
you know maybe Oh it'll be all all good
but you know that's something you got a
you got a hash out and that's that's the
majority of the cases when someone's
doing something like that it's they they
see something that could be improved and
you got to kind of win them over to get
them to tell you or maybe they'll just
tell you and you won't like me who knows
but you do have to you do have to
appreciate other people's points of view
even if they're wrong and maybe they are
maybe they'll tell you the thing and
you'll analyze it and say hey that
doesn't seem quite right to me here's
what I think and maybe it's worth
talking to them about or maybe not on
that something you got to kind of hash
out the situation situation
so just sort of an interesting thing
sort of a way to get involved with any
team without being shunned out right
away is to just really have a an open
mind in a sense of humor
not and not get bent out of shape about
things easily
I think this is a really valuable thing
that a surprising amount of people lack
just such a surprising amount of people
I think people this is something that in
interviews that should be tested against
and it's different because in interviews
they don't also don't want to deter you
because they you know they want people
to actually work for them but if they
hire someone on and they find out that
that person's just always crass
that person not necessarily gonna be
very helpful they might not make it very
long in the job anyway so you know
that's one of the things that
interviewer should should always do and
if they don't it might it might be a
sign of an issue they should always
trying to feel like personality and see
if see if you can handle a little bit of
flak absolutely lightheartedness about
it
and here for a healthy company and
healthy team anyway this is all my
opinion let me know what you think maybe
you have some more thoughts or
Corrections whatever made me happy to
hear and have any discuss further
so yeah this has kind of been a tutorial
about
how to have a sense of humor why
it's in the next one it's out